welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the guy who was
stupid enough to think that people would
finally be happy after the release of
the Schneider cut if you've been keeping
up with the developing story then you
know that in the wake of it there's been
a lot of posts about how Ben Affleck is
replacing Robert Pattinson the Batman is
being canceled and a lot more stupidity
I actually got into it with a Twitter
account last night that was talking
about how the Batman was definitely
going to be canceled and throughout this
video we're gonna be breaking down why
this doesn't make any sense isn't true
and it's one of the stupidest arguments
ever I feel like at the moment we've
become clickbait Busters in regards to
the movie but we're gonna be going over
the main points that are saying why it's
definitely being cancelled and why if
you use your brain for more than two
seconds you'll realize it's not don't
think too much brain you'll hit yourself
anyway make sure you subscribe to the
channel because we do break downs like
this every day and please drop a thumbs
up if you're not a sucker
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown of
why the Batman isn't getting canceled
okay so firstly before we get into this
I'm just gonna say up top that I've
blurred the person's name out who I was
talking to about this if you're that
bothered about seeing who it is then
it's still on my Twitter feed of heavy
spoilers but they did end up getting a
lot of backlash and I kind of ended the
conversation by saying that I wouldn't
add fuel to the fire
I don't really want someone harassed
over their opinion of a movie but yeah
this argument still needs to be talked
about because it's slowly popping up
everywhere now whilst this isn't the
only person writing this stuff as it's
the only one I've interacted with I feel
like I kind of need to show my logic
versus tears this is pretty much going
to be argument the video and hopefully
it's not too boring for you now before
we get into this I have to say that the
person who made the tweets is an actor
that starred in DUMBO some amazon prime
shows and more because of this their
opinions seemingly holds a lot more
weight than mine but this is why we kind
of have to shut down these rumors more
because they come from a place that
speaks with some authority it's even
gotten to the point that the clown
crowd were wondering whether James
Gunn's Suicide Squad was going to still
be released after rumors of the a
occurred surfaced and yeah this is
getting beyond a joke so we have to nip
it in the bud anyway obviously you can
make your mind up as we go through this
and if you're if you're on their side
then I'm gonna come round and beat you
up I'll find you I've got your IP
address so initially Brandon Davis asked
whether people would be up for seeing
Ben Affleck continuing as the Dark
Knight in the DCU whilst Robert
Pattinson exists in a separate universe
the person then said that they think
that the Batman will be scrapped and
then this slowly started to pick up
steam with a lot of other accounts
jumping in and saying that they'd heard
that too that things had fallen through
that haven't been reported yet and
people are just freaking out and
everybody has started losing their minds
I've included an example of this but I
know that Jezebel sits in the same camp
as me where we think that these rumors
are just absolutely ridiculous so I call
this out and said that there was no way
that Warner Brothers would scrap one of
the biggest movies of 2021 because a
movie from 2017 with some extra scenes
in it it's getting released on a
streaming service obviously if you've
been following the channel then you'll
know we report on the Schneider Kerr a
lot and we're aware that it's just more
than some extra scenes and so on but you
know you only get a certain amount of
characters per tweet so you've got to
make it snappy
now what also happens in arguments on
the internet that you might have just
noticed is that when someone can't
actually argue the point they're trying
to make they instead take an
insignificant part of your point and
then blow it out of proportion in order
to derail the argument this happens with
spelling mistakes often like I've done
it you've done it we've all done it so
we can win an argument on Facebook
anyway this happens a lot throughout
this argument but I'll try and keep my
points at least succinct so this guy
let's call him Joss Whedon for
argument's sake he starts talking about
the Snyder Kerr rather than the fact
that he talked about how Batman was
being canceled because he thinks a
streaming service is more important to
the release of a movie this is a dumb
argument and I followed it up by the
main point that everyone seems to be
forgetting in all of this what if Warner
Brothers just released them both like
they're doing already
sorry put your logic that they'd stub a
movie that's
past the billion mark for some HBO Mac
subscriptions is way off now what I mean
by this is it's very likely that Batman
will pass the billion mark if we look at
Aquaman Joker Captain Marvel and more
all of which I said to him he doesn't
think that they will just because he
doesn't but bear in mind that Batman is
the highest selling comic book character
of all time even his side characters
passed the billion marks these days so
if a movie is good and is well received
which let's be real Matt Reeves is yet
to really make a bad movie then it will
probably hit it if I'm wrong and it
doesn't hit the bill I'll eat my bat
sorry that I need to stop doing that
joke but again this guy let's call him
Kevin foggy foggy man's sake he
disagrees with that I love trying to try
and do his voice the hundreds of movies
didn't flawed logic mate don't get your
hopes at high it's about movie quality
no box-office Captain Marvel is a great
example of low quality high box-office
so I'm not sure what they argue in there
they think that because hundreds of
movies didn't pass a billion mark that
Batman can't and that Captain Marvel is
an example of a low quality movie
getting a high box-office which are the
notice does that prove my point that
comic book characters do well I don't
know so then I says let's call me Halle
Berry's Catwoman for argument's sake I
says you're kind of changing the
argument and injecting your opinion into
it to try and divert it from the fact
that you think the Batman which is mid
production will be canceled on a hunch
he then replies with me production um
star of film in Feb should own a modulo
I follow that up by saying yes filming
isn't the entire production of a film is
it you have pre-production set building
costume design scripting location
scouting etc etc filming isn't the start
of the
action that's how I sound on my head bit
bit like James James Bond in it really
anyway Dominic Cummings which we'll call
him for argument's sake since they
talked about the same amount of crap
tries to one-up me a bit and brings out
their have have you bothered to see what
I do full living so yeah if you work on
a movie as an extra you're definitely
smarter than me for thinking that
production only happens when the movie
starts filming slow clap I realized this
wasn't going anywhere and no matter what
point I came back with they would find
the most pedantic part of the tweet and
then change the argument to that they
were getting a load of crap at this
point and I decided to bail mainly so I
could passively aggressively make a
video that they couldn't really respond
to
up yours Dumbo so the point still
remains though that Warner Brothers will
not be cancelling this movie just last
week both Colin Farrell and Jeffrey
Wright were giving interviews on the
project and even if this guy here thinks
it's only been in production since
February the movie has likely been
worked on for at least a year it takes
time to write scripts then do a draft do
another draft to go through casting set
building and so on and Warner Brothers
at this point will likely have put up
towards at least fifty million into the
project I would say the Snyder cut is
improving and they will not cancel the
film no matter what anyone tells you if
Pattinson gets his trilogy as predicted
then they will make I would say at least
two billion at the box office which is
no small amount of money to throw away
whilst the Snyder coat will likely boost
subscriptions to HBO max it will not
equal two billion dollars in revenue no
matter what the fan base seems to say
Warner Brothers can do both they are
doing both nothing that they've said
should make you think otherwise both
projects can come out and coexist much
in the same way that Halle Quinn's
character who is tied to the Leto
version of the Joker can come out whilst
Joaquin Phoenix's exists I hate saying
Joaquin Phoenix because I always
pronounce it wrong anyway just shut up
stop believing people whose source is
dude bro trust me before venom joined
the MCU we saw that Spiderman was
coexisting alongside him fine so it
makes absolutely no sense the only
reason that this rumor is picking up any
steam is because for
some reason the section of the Schneider
Cup fanbase has got it into their heads
that Ben will be coming back and that
all they need to do in order to make
this happen is derail a Pattinson
project Athletic has said numerous times
and he's not going to be returning he's
told you this isn't like the Schneider
Cup where it was teased and he's
flat-out said no also guys just a lesson
in life if someone says no just take it
as a no now in order to add more
evidence to why the film isn't being
cancelled I went and checked out Kevin
Smith's flat man be on podcast which
talked about the Snider cut release
Smith had a video message from Affleck
in it and also talked about the project
itself and how it had come about
he said that Snider was approached by
Warner Brothers last November to
complete the cut and that it's been
worked on since then but the pandemic
has held it up so why would Warner Bros
do this and then also start filming the
Batman if they were planning on
cancelling it it just doesn't make any
sense I know most of you already know
this but yeah we have to keep telling
these people to stop these rumors the
Snyder cut came out because of some
exceptional circumstances firstly
Snyder's daughter committed suicide so
he had to step away from the project the
film is also the most talked about movie
on Twitter and Warner Bros history and
they confirmed this to Smith all the
actors involved called out for it and
the fanbase did to Warner Brothers
wanted a big title for their streaming
service that wouldn't cost the full
amount of a new film and thus the stars
aligned and things went ahead this isn't
the way that things will be happening
all the time no matter how many bloggers
tried to tell you that this sets a bad
precedent for films going forward we
won't be getting a Josh Trank Fantastic
Four cut because frankly the interest
isn't there like how it is with the
Snyder code we will probably be getting
the eya cut but again that's not a
massive investment for Warner's as it's
almost done
so yeah overall we need to start calling
out these rumors before they pick up any
headway as there's no evidence for them
and in fact the evidence points to the
contrary dude bro trust me isn't a
source a hunch it isn't a hunch no
matter how movies you worked on and it
just makes no sense anyway we can all
rest now
what's that Karen oh my god what oh my
god I'm just hearing from my sources now
that Warner Brothers want to bring back
Heath Ledger as the Joker and that
they're completely scrapping Joaquin
Phoenix's version I'll keep you up to
date with the story dude bro trust me as
it develops but in the meantime I'd love
to hear your thoughts on this rumor if
you actually believe it or if you know
it's probably not true comment below and
let us know and if you enjoy this video
then please drop a thumbs up and make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
rumors that ben affleck is replacing
Robert Pattinson is Batman we go over
why it's not the case why you need to
ignore this stuff so is it a fun video
or watch I'll let you decide if you want
to support the channel from as little as
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat to us
after the show either follow us at heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below every month we
give away free movies to people are
subscribed to the channel and this month
II can win the Marvel phase 3 part 2 you
box and all you have to do is comment on
a video and make sure you subscribe with
notifications on the more videos you
comment on the more you have a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
but when it's going to be chosen at
random on the 15th of June and the set
will be shipped out from mentor gets the
price it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like it
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition you
the best I'll see you next time take
care
[Music]
[Music]